In a world constantly clamoring
for attention, where I mean
every brand, every individual
seems to be chasing the next
fleeting growth hack or quick
visibility trick, it's
incredibly easy to feel
overwhelmed, right?
To feel lost in all that noise.
It often feels like everyone's
searching for that one magic
button to instant success.
Yet true, lasting digital
influence, the kind that
actually sticks and resonates,
can feel incredibly elusive.
Almost like a mythical creature,
Wouldn't you agree?
Today we're embarking on a
fascinating deep dive into a
company that fundamentally
challenges that quick fix
mentality, Meritus Media.
They approach digital influence
from what they call a truly
unique 360° perspective.
Our source for this exploration
is a compelling blog post by
Chris Abraham, aptly titled Why
I Joined Meritus Media, A 360°
Confluence of PRSCO and Digital
Influence.
Our mission today is to truly
unpack this concept of
confluence, to understand what
it means to genuinely shape
influence, to craft compelling
narrative, and to build enduring
visibility.
This isn't about fleeting
tactics.
It's about an integrated,
authentic approach that stands
the test of time.
We'll explore the deep legacy,
the unique methodology, and the
forward thinking vision that
truly sets Meritus Media apart.
Get ready to have some
fundamental ideas about digital
strategy not just shifted, but
perhaps even revolutionized.
Because here's where it gets
really interesting.
It's striking how the source
immediately challenges our
common perceptions of a typical
digital agency, isn't it?
It explicitly frames Meredith's
media not as a 1 trick pony or
as the article cleverly puts it,
a rented warehouse of tactics,
which, let's be honest, is a
common pitfall for many agencies
today, but rather is a
confluence.
A confluence exactly.
This isn't just a clever word,
it's critical.
It suggests a powerful, organic
merging of different streams,
much like rivers flowing
together to form a much larger,
more powerful body of water.
Rather than just a disparate
collection of separate services.
It truly implies a natural
strong coming together of forces
that are, you know, meant to
work in harmony.
That makes sense.
It paints a very different
picture.
It does, and Chris Abraham, with
his extensive background in SEO,
online reputation management or
RM as it's often called, and
broader digital strategy,
clearly found a profound
alignment with his integrated
vision.
His decision, as he puts it, to
step behind the shield of the
agency isn't a casual move.
It signals a deep commitment to
a particular ethos, one that he
unequivocally feels genuinely
works in shaping influence not
just in the digital landscape
but, as the source emphasizes,
in the real world's too.
So real world impact, not just
online metrics.
Precisely.
It's a powerful statement of
conviction from someone who has
spent years in the trenches
witnessing what truly drives
results versus what's just,
well, fleeting hype.
As we peel back the layers of
this deep dive, it's worth
asking ourselves, you know, what
does lasting visibility truly
mean in today's rapidly changing
media landscape?
Especially when so much of what
we encounter online feels so
transient?
So here today, gone tomorrow.
That's a powerful question to
keep at the forefront of our
minds.
Definitely.
Speaking of lasting impact, the
source makes a very strong claim
that Meredith's media isn't just
a business, but a continuation
of a profound legacy,
particularly through the
pioneering work of Sally Falkow.
The article boldly states she's
a name that should be studied in
every digital PR curriculum, if
one actually existed.
That's a huge assertion, isn't
it?
What exactly makes her influence
so utterly significant in this
space?
Yeah, that's a strong statement.
But the claim isn't hyperbole.
It really isn't when we connect
this to the bigger picture.
Sally Falca was described as a
pioneer and the source is very
deliberate clarifying it's not
in some cheesy tech process
only.
Just buzzwords.
You know, she was genuinely in
the trenches.
This isn't about buzzwords or
superficial innovation.
It's about tangible, impactful
contributions during an era when
public relations was
fundamentally and dramatically
different, the article reminds
us.
This was back when PR
professionals were still mailing
press releases and journalists
still answered phone calls.
Wow.
Hard to imagine now.
Exactly.
Think about the inertia she
faced.
Traditional PR was deeply
entrenched in physical mail,
phone calls, and carefully
curated media lists.
To not only foresee but actively
champion a digital
transformation then required
immense foresight, courage and
frankly, A willingness to
challenge the established norms.
It truly speaks to her audacious
vision.
So.
What were some of those key
contributions?
Well, her incredible foresight
with the social media news
release, or SMNR, is a prime
example.
She was championing this
concept, essentially A
multimedia interactive press
release designed for the web,
long before industry giants like
PR Newswire or Business Wire
even began to consider similar
approaches.
Oh yes, Imagine a world where
press releases were just black
text on white paper, mailed or
faxed.
The SMNR was revolutionary
because it was digital first.
It integrated images, video
links, shareable elements.
It transformed a static document
into an interactive hub for
journalists and the public.
This demonstrates an extremely
early and profound understanding
of how digital channels would
utterly transform content
dissemination and engagement.
She was anticipating changes
rather than merely reacting to
them.
That sounds incredibly ahead of
its time.
It really was, and her
professional standing and
influence are truly undeniable.
Her career spans over 30 years
in PR, which is a testament to
her longevity and adaptability
in such a dynamic field.
She holds the prestigious APR
accreditation for the Public
Relations Society of America,
PRSA, which is a mark of high
level experience and
professional achievement.
And importantly, she was named
PR Trainer of the Year by PR
News in 2009.
This isn't just an award, it
speaks volumes about her ability
to educate and empower others.
The fact that she's trained over
2500 executives, effectively
shaping the minds of countless
professionals, and has been
consistently ranked among the
top 50 PR and social media
influencers by scision, well
that solidifies her deep
industry credibility and
widespread impact.
So now she's doing it, but
teaching it too.
Exactly.
This isn't just about crafting
theories, it's about practical
application and sharing that
knowledge widely and effectively
building a new generation of
digital PR practitioners.
And this is truly fascinating.
She launched one of the very
first PR blogs in 2003. 2003 for
APR blog.
Yes, let's pause and consider
that time frame 2003 blogging
was still a nascent, almost
niche activity, particularly for
established professionals in
fields like PR, which were
historically slow to adopt new
technologies.
Her blog consistently ranked in
the top 20, demonstrating its
enduring quality and relevance
even back then.
This was a remarkably bold move,
signaling her commitment to
directly engaging with digital
platforms, really understanding
their power for direct
communication and thought
leadership long before it became
standard practice.
Well, it takes.
Guts it really has for the more
her landmark guide Smart News
how to create branded content
that gets found in search and
shared on social media directly
address the convergence of PR
content and search.
This is a concept that was far
from mainstream back then.
She was essentially mapping out
the future of digital PR before
many even saw the contours of
the landscape, predicting the
integration of SEO principles
into traditional PR.
Wow, connecting PR and SEO way
back then.
Absolutely.
And what's truly remarkable, as
the source emphasizes, is that
her thinking continues to evolve
alongside the industry.
She's not resting on past
laurels, she's constantly
integrating new insights on AI's
evolving role in PR,
sophisticated analytics,
measurement strategies and the
ever shifting landscape of
content relevance.
This adaptability is the
hallmark of true expertise.
It's what allows her legacy to
remain incredibly relevant and
forward-looking even today.
So always learning, always
adapting.
Exactly.
True pioneers don't just
innovate once, they continuously
push the boundaries.
Perhaps most profoundly, though,
her approach to earning coverage
truly stands out.
The source makes a very clear
distinction, and it's a crucial
one.
She didn't treat journalists or
bloggers as targets.
She treated them like
collaborators.
Collaborators, not targets.
I like that.
Right.
And significantly, she didn't
buy coverage.
She earned it through context,
clarity and relevance.
This is a foundational principle
of ethical, impactful PR that
Meredith's media clearly
champions.
It directly counters.
The transactional approach is
still prevalent today where many
see quick mentions or paid
placements.
Her model is about building
genuine reciprocal relationships
and providing real newsworthy
value, leading to more
sustainable and credible
outcomes.
It sounds like a much more,
well, human approach.
It is this is a vital counter
narrative to those who still
believe influence can simply be
purchased, highlighting that
true influence is built on
trust, not transactions.
That commitment to
collaboration, to earning
influence rather than buying it,
isn't just theoretical.
The source gives us a fantastic,
tangible example with the Mizuno
running campaign.
Tell us about that first real
campaign and what exactly made
it so effective.
It's such a vivid illustration
of PR with running shoes on.
It's a great story and it truly
encapsulates Meredith's
philosophy.
What's fascinating here is the
origin story of Chris Abraham
and Sally Falkow's professional
relationship, starting at a
company called Social Ally.
It wasn't just a business
meeting, it set the stage for a
shared understanding and trust
in this very particular
relationship.
First approach to digital
outreach.
Their collaboration began with
this very campaign, indicating
that this ethos was present from
the genesis of their joint work.
So they were aligned from the
start.
Seems like it.
It's the kind of foundational
experience that defines A
partnership.
The source details a pivotal
campaign for Mizuno running,
executed through a digital
agency in Boston.
That, crucially, had the
foresight to trust in real
Blogger outreach rather than a
pay for postmodel.
OK.
That distinction again, real
outreach versus pay for post.
Exactly this highlights a
critical, almost philosophical
distinction right at the outset.
On one side you have the short
term transactional pay for
Postmodel, which let's face it
off in a roads trust and
authenticity as content creators
are seen as mere billboards.
On the other, you have
relationship driven engagement
which builds lasting
credibility.
The agency's willingness to
invest in the latter approach
was absolutely foundational to
the campaign's profound success.
They understood the genuine
connection would yield far more
than a simple transaction.
So how did they structure it?
What was the tactical
brilliance?
Yes, the tactical brilliance lay
in their coordination of an
outreach program that offered
running influencers 1-2 or even
3 pairs of shoes not as payment,
but is gear to test, use and
share.
Not as payment, but his gear.
That's subtle.
Subtle, but absolutely crucial.
It changes the entire dynamic.
It positioned the shoes as tools
for an authentic experience and
genuine feedback, rather than a
commodity for a sponsored
mention.
Influencers weren't being paid
to endorse, they were being
provided with a product to
genuinely integrate into their
lives, to train in, to
experience first hand and then
to share their real experiences,
whether positive or negative.
So it encouraged honest
feedback.
Precisely this fostered a level
of integrity that monetary
transactions often lack and is,
frankly, often missing in
today's influencer landscape.
And the results.
Profound, according to the
source.
If we connect this to the bigger
picture, the campaign generated
authentic content, trusted
voices, and earned influence.
This wasn't merely about getting
product mentions, it was about
generating genuine engagement
from individuals who genuinely
used and believed in the
product.
The content produced came from a
place of real lived experience,
making it far more relatable and
trustworthy for their audiences.
When a runner sees their
favorite influencer genuinely
logging miles in a pair of
shoes, it carries far more
weight than a staged photo.
PR with running shoes on.
I get it now.
Exactly.
It perfectly encapsulates this
blend of practical product
experience and strategic public
relations, emphasizing the hands
on authentic nature of the
approach.
It speaks to a deep belief that
the most effective PR comes from
real interaction and genuine
belief in the product or
service.
That really brings to mind how
critical authenticity has
become, especially with consumer
skepticism seemingly at an all
time high these.
Days it really has.
Which raises a really important
question for today, especially
in an era saturated with
sponsored content, where it
feels like every other social
media post is in hashtag ad
right?
How can brands still achieve
this level of authentic, earned
influence?
The Mizuno example provides a
clear blueprint for fostering
genuine advocacy rather than
just transactional endorsement.
It underscores that trust and
relevance often yield far
greater returns and build
deeper, more resilient brand
loyalty than direct payment or
simple affiliate marketing,
which the source explicitly
differentiates this campaign
from.
So it's about creating real
advocates, not just hiring
spokespeople.
Exactly.
It's not about buying ad space,
it's about creating evangelists
who genuinely champion your
brand.
This feels more relevant than
ever.
Definitely.
So building on that powerful
legacy and those genuinely
authentic campaigns, let's
really dive into what Meritus
Media does and why the source so
heavily emphasizes that it's not
siloed, but truly 360.
That's a bold claim in an
industry often highly segmented
by specialists.
From your perspective, what does
this deeply integrated approach
truly entail?
That's precisely the core of
their differentiation.
What's truly distinctive here is
the explicit rejection of silo
services, the source states
unequivocally.
It's not siloed, it's 360.
This isn't just a marketing
slogan they paste on their
website.
It implies A deeply holistic
strategy where each component
reinforces and amplifies the
others, creating a cohesive and
powerful overall impact.
So everything working together.
Exactly.
It's not simply about offering
many services under one roof.
It's about integrating them
seamlessly so they work in
concert rather than as
independent units that might
even compete with each other.
It's about recognizing that in
the digital world, every single
touch point effects another, and
optimizing them in isolation is,
well, kind of a fool's errand.
OK, so break that down for us.
What are the different parts of
this 360 approach?
Right, let's unpack each
service's unique angle within
this 360° approach, because
that's where the integration
truly shines.
First, they offer digital PR
with deep journalistic roots.
Journalistic Roots.
Yes, this signifies an
unwavering emphasis on
storytelling, truth, and genuine
news value.
It moves far beyond mere
promotional fluff to creating
narratives that truly resonate
with media and audiences because
they're well researched,
compelling, and offer real
value, much like a seasoned
journalist would approach a
story.
They earn media through merit,
not just by mass mailing press
releases.
For instance, instead of just
announcing a new product
feature, they might craft a
narrative around the real world
problem it solves, interviewing
early adopters, painting a vivid
picture of its impact, making it
genuinely newsworthy.
Got it.
What's next?
Next, the reputation management
goes beyond mere cleanup and
leads heavily into narrative
creation.
This is a significant
philosophical shift.
It transforms reputation
management from a reactive
damage control function just
fixing problems after they occur
to a proactive brand building. 1
It's about actively shaping
positive perceptions through
compelling stories and strategic
communication, rather than
simply mitigating negative ones.
For example, if a client is in a
sensitive industry, Meredith
might proactively launch a
series of articles highlighting
their commitment to ethical
practices or community
involvement, building a positive
brand narrative that acts as a
buffer.
So building resilience before a
crisis hits.
Exactly.
This raises an important
question.
How does narrative creation
prevent reputational issues
rather than just fixing them?
By building a strong, authentic
brand story beforehand, you
create a foundation of trust
that can withstand minor
criticisms or provide context if
larger challenges arise.
Makes sense?
Then there's SEO.
Yes, there's search engine
optimization that's strategic,
technical, and holistic.
This actively avoids the common
SEO trick mentality, you know,
where agencies might just focus
on keyword stuffing or quick
Black Hat hacks that yield short
term gains but long term
penalties.
Instead, it emphasizes a deep
ethical understanding of search
algorithms alongside a broader
strategy that critically
considers user experience,
website architecture, and the
overall quality of content.
Holistic here means full
integration with content
strategy, web development and
overarching brand messaging.
So SEO isn't just an add on.
Not at all.
It's a foundational element
embedded from the very
beginning.
They might, for instance,
analyze user search intent, then
optimize not just keywords, but
the entire content structure and
user flow on a page to satisfy
that intent, leading to better
rankings and engagement.
OK, Influencer marketing, I
imagine that follows the Mizuno
example.
You got it.
Their influencer marketing is
built on relationships, not
transactions.
Echoing the Mizuno example we
discussed earlier.
This reiterates their profound
commitment to authentic
connections over simple
payments.
It implies a focus on
cultivating long term
partnerships and genuine
advocacy rather than just
chasing reach numbers through
one off sponsored posts.
This aligns perfectly with Sally
Falcao's ethos of collaboration
and earned influence.
Consistency in the philosophy.
Absolutely ensuring that the
message comes from a place of
genuine belief and passion,
leading to more credible and
impactful recommendations.
They might invest time in
identifying influencers who
genuinely align with a brand's
values, fostering a relationship
built on shared interest rather
than just a fee.
And what?
Development.
How does that fit in?
Good question.
They offer a web development and
UX that aligns directly with
brand story and performance
goals.
This ensures that the technical
foundation of a brand's online
presence isn't just functional
but also actively enhances the
brand narrative and supports
overall marketing objectives.
It means the user experience,
how easy, intuitive and
enjoyable a website is to
navigate, is seen as an integral
part of the brand story itself,
directly contributing to
conversion, retention and brand
perception, not just aesthetics.
Sub website is part of the
story.
Exactly.
A user friendly site that
reflects the brand's personality
is inherently more trustworthy
and effective.
And then there's social media
marketing, handled with a focus
on voice, not just volume.
Voice, not volume.
What does that mean practically?
It's a crucial distinction.
It moves beyond simply posting
frequently or chasing fleeting
viral trends, which can often
lead to generic or shallow
engagement.
Instead, it emphasizes the
development of a distinct,
authentic brand voice that truly
resonates with an audience,
fostering meaningful engagement
over mere impressions or
superficial likes.
It's about the quality of
interaction, building community,
and participating in
conversations in a way that
feels genuine and adds value.
They might focus on community
management and thoughtful
responses over merely pushing
out scheduled posts.
Quality over quantity.
Precisely and finally, their
content strategy understands
both Google and humans equally.
This dual focus is absolutely
crucial in today's landscape.
Google and humans.
That's a balancing act.
It is.
It's not just about keyword
stuffing for algorithms to rank
higher, nor is it merely about
creative writing for human
appeal.
It's about creating content that
is genuinely valuable, readable,
shareable, and emotionally
resonant for human audiences,
while simultaneously being
technically optimized for search
visibility and algorithmic
understanding.
This ensures content isn't just
found, it's also consumed,
appreciated, and acted upon.
They understand that if content
isn't engaging for people,
Google won't value it for long
anyway.
That holistic view again, right?
If we connect all these pieces
to the bigger picture, the
source beautifully summarizes
this seamless integration.
It's everything not stitched
together haphazardly, but
flowing from one integrated
approach.
From thought leadership to
schema markup, from crisis
response to long tail keyword
capture, from brand defense to
brand acceleration.
It illustrates A seamless
strategic continuum across all
digital touch points where every
single piece.
BASE works in harmony towards a
unified overarching goal.
It truly describes A holistic,
interconnected system designed
for maximum sustained impact.
So not just a collection of
services, but a system.
Think of it less like a
collection of talented soloists
and more like a finely tuned
orchestra.
Each instrument or service is
excellent on its own, but when
conducted by a master, which is
what Meredith Media's integrated
approach aims to be, they
produce a powerful Symphony,
true harmonious and impactful
digital influence that is far
greater than the sum of its
parts.
That orchestra analogy really
brings it to life.
It's not just about having the
pieces, but about how they
conduct them.
So with this incredibly
integrated model, the source
tells us the Falco legacy
continues through Mike Falkow,
Sally's son, and his brother
Jonathan.
It paints a picture of a unique
blend of creativity and strategy
at the helm.
What's Mike's background, which
sounds anything but traditional,
And how does it specifically
contribute to this integrated
360° approach?
You're right, Mike Falco's
background is anything but
typical, and that's precisely
what makes it so fascinating and
valuable for Meredith's media.
His journey from a professional
surfer A.
Surfer.
Really.
Yep, professional surfer to a
web developer, a magazine art
director, and even an actor.
It's not what you conventionally
expect for the CEO of a digital
agency, but this diverse
background provides A deeply
intuitive, multifaceted
understanding of elements
critical to effective digital
influence.
A RO surfer understands flow
balance, adapting instantly to
dynamic environments like the
digital landscape.
OK.
I can see that connection.
A web developer understands
structure functionality, an art
director grasps visual
communication, brand identity,
and an actor understands
narrative, empathy, how to
authentically connect with an
audience, embody a story.
This unusual combination allows
Meredith to approach problems
from angles that blend both
rigorous analytics and
compelling artistry, leading to
truly innovative solutions.
That makes a lot of sense
actually.
Art and science combined.
Exactly.
Under his leadership, Meredith
has significantly grown its
global presence, expanding to
key hubs like Los Angeles, Tampa
and the UK.
His ability to blend creative
instincts with strategic
direction is absolutely key to
their success and embodies the
art and analytics philosophy we
discussed earlier.
It implies that Meredith's media
isn't just data-driven or just
creatively driven.
It's both recognizing that
successful digital campaigns
require both analytical rigor
and compelling artistry.
Knowing what to do and how to do
it well.
Precisely bringing the strategy
to life with impactful creative
execution.
And his brother is involved,
too.
Yes, the mention of his brother
Jonathan Cokie Falco, who is
also a performer and writer and
leads business development in
Europe, further emphasizes this
creative and narrative driven
DNA within the family.
It's clear this isn't just
Mike's personal philosophy, but
a shared family philosophy and
business culture that underpins
how Meritus Media operates
operates globally.
It creates A consistent approach
rooted in performance,
storytelling, and strategic
growth.
So that creative spark runs deep
in the agency.
It seems so.
This collaborative leadership
infused with creative
backgrounds undoubtedly fosters
a culture of innovation and
adaptability.
This really raises an important
question.
How does having this rare blend
of art, analytics, authenticity,
and ambition within the
leadership directly translate
into Meredith's Media's actual
service delivery and their
client relationships?
Yeah.
How does it play out day-to-day?
It strongly suggests that these
values aren't just buzzwords on
their website or aspirational
statements.
There live principles that
profoundly shape how they treat
clients, how they approach
problem solving, and how they
define success and digital
influence.
It suggests A genuine commitment
to their integrated philosophy
where creativity informs
strategy, authenticity guides
execution, and ambition drives
continuous improvement.
This leadership model itself
serves as a testament to the
integrated human centric
approach.
Meritus.
Media.
Champions.
That's a powerful testament to
leadership by example,
Definitely.
So after exploring Meritus
Media's integrated model and its
unique leadership, the source
circles back to Chris Abraham's
core motivation for joining
them.
It boils down to three very
succinct points.
This model works, the people
behind it are real, and Sally's
enduring ethos.
Let's really dive into that
ethos.
What is it at its heart, and why
is it so incredibly fundamental
to every fiber of Meredith's
media?
This is truly the bedrock of
everything they do.
What's profoundly significant
here is the reiteration that
this model works for someone
like Chris Abraham, who spent
decades immersed in the field
SEOORM digital strategy.
This isn't a speculative claim
or a hopeful wish.
It's proven for him.
Exactly.
It's a confirmed reality based
on years of practical
observation and tangible
results.
His decision to join isn't based
on a theoretical alignment, but
on the proven efficacy of
Meredith's media's integrated
relationship First approach,
which he has seen deliver
consistent, measurable outcomes.
It's an endorsement built on
solid evidence.
And the people, the people
behind it, are real.
Yeah, that statement, because
the people behind it are real,
speaks volumes to the human
element at Meredith's media
score.
In a digital world that can
often feel impersonal,
transactional, and increasingly
filled with automation,
emphasizing authenticity
personnel suggests a culture
built on genuine trust, real
connection, and profound
transparency.
This is absolute crucial for
fostering long term deep
partnerships with clients and
influencers alike.
It means that conversations are
authentic, advice is sincere,
and the people you work with are
genuinely invested in your
success, not just going through
the motions.
That human centered approach
again, right?
It fundamentally differentiates
Meritus Media in a crowded,
often cold market, and if we
truly connect this to the bigger
picture, Sally's ethos is
explicitly identified as the
standard.
The standard, not just a
guideline.
Not just a guideline, it's
something baked into the
process, into the people, into
the way Merida's treats clients
not as budgets, but as
collaborators.
This is the absolute crux of
their unique selling
proposition.
Treating clients as
collaborators.
Exactly.
It implies that every
interaction, every strategic
decision, every piece of content
creation is infused with Sally's
core principles, making their
approach consistent, ethical,
and deeply relational.
So what?
Are those core principles that
ethos?
It's defined by three powerful
interconnected components.
Journalism first.
Relationship first.
Truthful influence.
Let's break those down because
they are more profound than they
sound.
First, journalism first.
This implies A profound, almost
sacred commitment to factual
accuracy, compelling
storytelling, and earning media
through sheer merit, not through
paid placements or deceptive
practices.
It's about creating content and
narratives that are inherently
newsworthy, relevant, and
provide genuine value.
Like a meticulous journalist.
Credibility is key.
Absolutely instilling a sense of
responsibility and credibility.
Second, relationship first.
This reinforces the idea of
treating journalists, bloggers,
influencers, and their own
clients as genuine
collaborators.
It's about building authentic
connections and fostering mutual
respect that yields sustainable
results over time.
It recognizes that true enduring
influence comes from trust and
rapport, not just from one off
interactions.
Partnership over transactions.
Yes, a direct counter to the
target mentality.
And 3rd, truthful influence.
This emphasizes unwavering
integrity and absolute
transparency in all digital
endeavors.
It means cultivating influence
based on undeniable credibility,
radical authenticity, and
genuine, demonstrable value.
It's about ensuring that the
narratives they craft and the
visibility they generate are
firmly based on reality and
genuinely earned trust, rather
than exaggeration or
manipulation.
Especially important today.
Critically important in an era
where misinformation can spread
rapidly, Truthful influence is
not just ethical, it is
strategically essential for long
term brand health and
resilience.
It's building influence that can
withstand scrutiny.
So back to that collaborator
point, how does treating clients
as collaborators rather than
budgets actually change the
dynamic of a project day-to-day?
That's a great question.
It suggests a much deeper
partnership, a shared investment
in outcomes and a far more
transparent working relationship
from the outset.
When clients are seen as
collaborators, they are truly
involved in the strategic
process, their insights are
genuinely valued and there's a
collective, unified effort
towards achieving shared goals.
It sounds much more like a team
effort.
Exactly.
It fundamentally shifts the
power dynamic from a typical
vendor client relationship to a
true team approach, which
ultimately leads to more
effective, sustainable and
satisfying results for the
client because they are truly
part of the journey and invested
in its success.
It fosters a sense of ownership
on both sides.
That commitment to deep
collaboration truly sounds like
a game changer in client
relationships.
OK, so as we wrap up this deep
dive, the source concludes by
looking forward, stating quite
definitively the future of
visibility is hybrid.
What exactly does that mean?
And what's the ultimate take
away for anyone out there trying
to navigate this incredibly
complex and ever evolving
digital world?
That concluding statement really
ties everything together
beautifully.
What's fascinating here is how
it synthesizes all the previous
points into a clear, concise
vision for the future.
Visibility is indeed hybrid.
This isn't just a trendy
buzzword, it's a profound
recognition that truly effective
digital presence in the modern
landscape requires A nuanced
blend of approaches.
Specifically means it's a mix of
organic and engineered and
earned and owned.
Organic and engineered, earned
and owned.
OK, right.
This acknowledges that while
organic reach built through
content quality and search
relevance and earned media
gained through genuine
relationships and newsworthiness
are paramount, trategic
engineered components also have
their vital place.
This could include highly
technical EO otimizations,
targeted paid amplification, or
deliberate content distribution
strategies.
It's not an either scenario.
It's about a smart, integrated
combination where each element
supports and amplifies the
others, creating a symbiotic
relationship.
So bringing different approaches
together strategically.
Exactly, and the source
beautifully articulates the
ideal balance needed for this
hybrid future with a powerful
and memorable analogy.
Visibility should be built with
the precision of an SEO and the
heart of a journalist.
Precision of an SEO heart of a
journalist.
I like that.
It's incredibly insightful,
right?
And truly captures the essence
of Meredith's media's approach.
The precision of an SEO refers
to the analytical, technical,
beta driven aspects.
Understanding complex
algorithms, leveraging keywords,
optimizing site architecture,
measuring performance metrics.
The science part.
Exactly.
The science and engineering of
getting found online, ensuring
content is structured so search
engines can understand and rank
it.
It's the technical backbone.
The heart of a journalist, on
the other hand, refers to the
ethical, narrative driven, truth
seeking and relationship
building aspects we've
discussed.
It's about crafting compelling
stories that resonate with human
audiences, earning trust through
credible reporting, building
those genuine connections.
The art and ethics part.
Precisely.
It's about understanding what
makes the story impactful, how
to convey it clearly, engage in
audience emotionally and
intellectually.
This blend ensures that content
is not only found through
technical precision, but also
valued, trusted, and acted upon
by human beings.
So it's truly the integration of
both sides.
That's the key.
If we connect this to the bigger
picture, Chris Abraham's
concluding statement is a direct
and powerful call to action for
you, the listener.
If you're looking to stop duct
taping digital services together
and start creating true digital
influence, you should be paying
attention.
Duct taking services together.
That paints a picture many can
relate to, I think.
Doesn't it?
It directly addresses the
learner persona's likely desire
for integrated, effective
solutions to information
overload and fragmented
strategies.
It suggests moving away from
piece meal reactive solutions
like trying to patch together
different vendors to a cohesive,
strategic whole.
It's an invitation to think more
holistically and long term about
your digital presence rather
than chasing individual,
isolated metrics.
A.
Call for a more integrated
strategy.
Definitely.
Ultimately, Chris Abraham's Why
I'm Here and Why I'm Building
alongside Mike Falkow and the
team at Meritus encapsulates his
profound conviction that this
integrated, authentic and
ethical approach is not just a
preference, it's truly the most
effective and sustainable path
forward for true digital
influence in our increasingly
complex world.
He's not just endorsing a
company, he's endorsing a
philosophy of how influence
should be built in the modern
age, one that prioritizes
integrity and long term value.
Which leaves us with a big
question.
It does a truly vital question
to ponder in a digital world
increasingly reliant on AI and
automation for content creation
and distribution.
How crucial will the human
touch, genuine relationships and
that core journalistic ethos
remain in building lasting
incredible influence?
Will authenticity become the
ultimate competitive advantage,
setting genuine voices apart
from the, well, the manufactured
noise?
That's a heavy question to end
on.
We've just journeyed through the
unique philosophy of Meritus
Media, seen so clearly through
Chris Abraham's eyes.
We've unpacked how a legacy
built on pioneering digital PRA,
profound commitment to authentic
relationships, and a genuinely
integrated 360° approach can
fundamentally redefine what
digital influence truly means.
It's clear this isn't just about
fleeting friends or simply
chasing algorithms.
It's about building something
truly sustainable, something
that resonates deeply because
it's rooted in integrity,
genuine connection, and
undeniable value.
Absolutely.
This deep dive has truly shown
us that truthful influence isn't
just a marketing buzzword, it's
a foundational principle that
guides every aspect of their
work.
It challenges us, really, to
think beyond isolated tactics
and consider how every single
piece of our digital presence
contributes to a cohesive,
authentic narrative.
The idea of earning attention
through context, clarity and
relevance, rather than simply
buying it, feels more vital than
ever in a world so full of noise
and distraction.
So what does this all mean for
you?
Navigating the complex world of
digital visibility, whether for
a personal brand or a business,
consider the transformative
power of this integrated
mindset.
Instead of patching together
disparate services or chasing
the latest short term hack,
imagine building your online
presence with what we've called
the precision of an SEO and the
heart of a journalist.
Creating a truly hybrid,
genuinely influential digital
footprint that not only gets
found, but more importantly,
stands the test of time and
builds real trust.
And here's a final thought for
you to chew on.
In a digital landscape
increasingly filled with AI
generated content and hyper
targeted ads, will the ability
to truly earn influence through
human connection, authentic
value and a steadfast commitment
to journalistic principles
become the ultimate
differentiator, forever setting
genuine voices apart from the
manufactured noise?